en el vídeo anterior me arrojé a mí
misma oa una moneda desde lo alto de un
precipicio iniciando con una velocidad
igual a cero porque me encontraba quieta
y al final llegaba yo a los 100 metros
por segundo y usamos estos datos para
conocer la altura del precipicio y
encontramos que el precipicio media 500
metros de altura lo que haremos ahora es
tratar de encontrar una fórmula general
para un problema similar digamos que
tienen como datos datos la velocidad
inicial la velocidad final y la
aceleración
desconocemos la distancia haciendo lo
mismo que hicimos en el vídeo anterior
sabemos que el cambio en la distancia va
a ser igual a la velocidad promedio por
la diferencia en el tiempo podemos
encontrar la velocidad promedio la
velocidad promedio es igual a la
velocidad final menos la velocidad
inicial entre 2 así que sustituimos esto
aquí en esta fórmula y nos queda que la
diferencia en distancia es igual a la
velocidad promedio que la velocidad
promedio acabamos de encontrar es esta
velocidad final menos velocidad inicial
entre 2
multiplicado por la diferencia en el
tiempo el tiempo lo podemos calcular
diciendo bueno sabemos qué tan rápido
estamos acelerando y sabemos la
velocidad inicial y final así que
podemos calcular cuánto tiempo tuvimos
que acelerar para alcanzar ese cambio en
la velocidad la forma más sencilla de
expresar esto es lo escribimos por acá
el cambio en la velocidad es igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo sabemos que la
diferencia de velocidad es la velocidad
final menos la velocidad inicial
esto es igual a la aceleración por el
tiempo
y si despejamos el tiempo de aquí vamos
a dividir ambos lados entre la
aceleración el tiempo va a ser igual a
la diferencia en velocidades velocidad
final menos velocidad inicial entre la
aceleración y ahora sustituimos estos
elementos aquí en nuestra fórmula
original la diferencia en la distancia
es igual a la velocidad promedio que es
esto velocidad final menos velocidad
inicial entre 2 esto de aquí
por la diferencia en el tiempo que es
esto el tiempo porque iniciamos desde un
tiempo cero así que ponemos esto de aquí
velocidad final menos velocidad inicial
/ aceleración
es esto de acá bueno simplificamos esto
y nos va a quedar el cambio en la
distancia es igual la velocidad final
menos velocidad inicial por velocidad
final menos velocidad inicial nos va a
quedar velocidad final al cuadrado menos
velocidad inicial al cuadrado entre 2
por la aceleración 2a podemos jugar con
esta fórmula si determinamos que la
distancia inicial es igual a cero
entonces en lugar de la diferencia de
distancia pondremos que la distancia es
igual a la velocidad final al cuadrado
menos la velocidad inicial al cuadrado
entre 2
dos veces la aceleración si
multiplicamos todo esto por 2a nos va a
quedar 2 por la aceleración por la
distancia igual a la velocidad final al
cuadrado
menos la velocidad inicial al cuadrado y
si despejamos la velocidad final al
cuadrado velocidad final al cuadrado es
igual esto pasa aquí sumando nos queda
la velocidad inicial al cuadrado más 2
por la aceleración por la distancia no
sé si han visto en su clase de física o
en sus libros pero seguramente alguna de
estas variaciones aparecerán en esos
libros pero la razón por la que quise
mostrarles el problema anterior primero
es para que ustedes se den cuenta de que
pueden resolver estos problemas sin
tener que memorizar las fórmulas y
aunque no es mala idea memorizar algunas
de estas fórmulas ustedes deben de
comprender cómo es que se llegó a estas
fórmulas
aplicarlas y ahora que conocen esta
fórmula general y que saben que no
tienen que memorizar la vamos a usar la
vamos a hacer un poco más despacio aquí
digamos que tengo el mismo precipicio
que en el problema anterior
en esta ocasión voy a lanzar mi moneda
primero hacia arriba en lugar de dejarla
caer
al momento de lanzarla hacia arriba va a
tener una velocidad de 30 metros por
segundo este positivo me indica que la
velocidad es hacia arriba el sentido de
la velocidad hacia donde estoy lanzando
la moneda es hacia arriba si fuera
negativo sería hacia abajo recordamos
que este precipicio tiene una altura de
500 metros usemos esta fórmula para
calcular la velocidad final de la moneda
cuando ésta llega al suelo así que aquí
cuando llegue aquí la moneda tendremos
que nuestra distancia final en este
punto es de menos 500 metros
ya que se recorrió toda esta distancia
hacia abajo bueno tenemos entonces
nuestra fórmula velocidad final al
cuadrado es igual me piden la velocidad
inicial en este caso si hay velocidad
inicial que es con la que lancé la
moneda hacia arriba así que la velocidad
inicial es de 30 metros por segundo lo
pongo positivo para indicar que fue
hacia arriba
velocidad inicial al cuadrado y ahora
sumó 2 por la aceleración que damos
desde el problema anterior que la
aceleración aquí es la de la gravedad y
para facilitar el cálculo la redondeamos
a 10 metros por segundo al cuadrado pero
como es hacia abajo el sentido de donde
nos está jalando la gravedad va a ser
menos 10 metros por segundo al cuadrado
y ahora lo multiplicamos por la
distancia y la distancia que tenemos que
es 500 metros hacia abajo va a ser menos
500 metros
los 500 metros
ahora simplificamos 30 al cuadrado va a
ser igual a 900
900 metros cuadrados por segundo al
cuadrado más 2 que multiplica a menos 10
x menos 500 menos por menos es más va a
quedar positivo 2 por 10 20 20 por 500
va a ser igual a 10 mil 10.000 y ahora
vemos las unidades metro por metro es
metro cuadrado entre segundo al cuadrado
muy bien ahora sólo nos resta hacer esta
suma de manera que la velocidad final al
cuadrado
nos quedan como 900 más 10 mil 10 mil
900 metros cuadrados entre segundos
cuadrados pero lo que me pregunten es la
velocidad final no la velocidad final al
cuadrado lo que tengo que hacer aquí es
sacar la raíz cuadrada de esto y de esto
de manera que mi velocidad final es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 10.900 que
más o menos se aproxima a ciento
4.403 metros por segundo lo redondeamos
a 104 metros por segundo aproximadamente
esta es mi velocidad final eso es
interesante porque en el problema
anterior cuando dejamos caer la moneda
al llegar al fondo ésta tuvo una
velocidad final de 100 metros por
segundo pero en esta ocasión si lanzó
hacia arriba la moneda a 30 metros por
segundo cuando la manera llegue al suelo
tendrá mayor velocidad así que podemos
pensar el porqué de esto y se darán
cuenta de que al lanzar la manera hacia
arriba se le está dando mayor altura es
decir va a estar cayendo más de 500
metros recorrerá una distancia positiva
y después recorrerá una distancia
negativa así que tendrá aún más tiempo
para acelerar creo que esto lo pueden
comprender de manera intuitiva y hasta
aquí llegamos en este vídeo y en el
siguiente continuaremos usando esta
fórmula para resolver otros problemas